this is the most powerful fire user in
all of anime and you might be thinking
that it's Ace or Sabo from one piece or
Dobby or Endeavor from my hero Academia
or maybe even someone like rengoku from
Demon Slayer and all of them are
incredibly strong their powers are
basically Child's Play compared to what
the top fire user can do now someone
like Natsu from Fairy Tale is a true
fire-eating monster because he can
overwhelm dragons with his fiery punches
and even Mel drops by simply walking
past but not even he is the strongest
and you might be thinking that it's
escanor from the seven deadly sins who
literally has the Blazing powers of the
Sun and can evaporate an entire Lake in
the blink of an eye however even his
Flames are a mere candle to the most
impressive fire user who is so powerful
that his Flames can turn anyone into Ash
with a single touch and that's the
captain commander of bleach gendu Sai
Yamamoto which must mean that